get the gargoyle King what is happening
in the town over thanks for flying in
witches I'm your High hostess Liana
Galera and this is the witches council
et's enchanting show that's all about
the chilling Adventures of Sabrina now
if you're like me than us be dying to
know when our milkshake loving teens of
Riverdale are going to be crossing over
into the frightfully fun town of
Greendale so this episode of witches
council is all about that bewitching
topic feel free to trample now when I
caught up with Kiernan Shipka Ross Lynch
and the rest of our chilling cast on set
they revealed their dream crossover
ideas the game began I feel like they
should wonder into our town or perhaps
they've lost someone I need a mortuary
the Spellman watery I still like the
idea of mortals coming across a
different world stay with your own kind
I would still love to solve mystery with
Jughead I would love to see Sabrina and
the core 4 go off and do some witchy
things all of them together like Archie
and Sabrina or doing wishy ask things
you come with me if you want I would
love like prudence and Cheryl just team
up I think that would be so badass oh my
god I can't don't know what kind of
trouble they would wreak or havoc they
would wreak Oh God
I think that would be epic with pleasure
Veronica I would also really love to see
Veronica's got this like um this like I
am Here I am woman hear me roar
Veronica Lodge is not about to go
quietly into the night I do think that
would be a lot of fun just to see how
those two worlds would collide and I
think the fans would love it and we do
this for them I got you something
there's so many possibilities but I
would really love to see Nick and
Jughead just riding a motorcycle
somewhere together like I can see it in
my mind just like I think that's our
bikes yeah I know you bro
yeah yeah let's go for a ride I'm taking
your bike
I'm just first of all a really big fan
of Lily's work I think that she's such a
wonderful actress every sign that she's
in she's just like pops so that's
probably why I want to do a scene with
Lily but I also feel like Roz and Betty
could get up to some good stuff together
wait what what mom ask your prayer I
think could probably do with a good slap
yeah I'd probably have to have to deal
with her
it's not big catty [ __ ] yeah so so
picture this it's just another day in
Riverdale you know the the squad Archie
Veronica
Betty Jughead er just you know sharing a
milkshake it pops talking about whatever
you know uncanny murder took place as
you do and the core four of Sabrina just
all of us are just chillin in a booth in
the back and it's never talked about
that's the crossover I'm really here for
exactly exactly my idea personally is
that I think that we need to get one of
the Riverdale characters over on our
show there's no way that there could be
like a real like merge of the two shows
I don't think that could ever happen
like do you remember when in Disney if I
did like that's so sweet life of Hannah
Montana oh we can't have that so sweet
life of Hannah Montana happen on this
show that we could talk to Cole and get
some sweet life on the show but not
anything else but I think that Archie
should just like wander over into
Greendale like he goes on runs he that
he's athletic he didn't run into
Greendale
he also runs into the most amount of
trouble so that would make the most
sense right I honestly think that Archie
hopping over on our show would be
awesome came as soon as I could I would
love to see all of those characters
interact and I have a very strong
feeling that the TV gods will be
conjuring up a Sabrina and Riverdale
crossover at some point we just might
need to wait a spell but now I want to
hear it from you witches give this video
a like and then cast your comments below
do you think that Cheryl and prudence
would be an unstoppable duo would
Jughead and Harvey get along and should
Sabrina and archie share a milkshake it
pops brew up your best crossover ideas
and i'll summon you again soon witches
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]